all right chris sims recently on the
unbuttoned podcast redrafted the top 10
from the 2017 nfl draft and to no
surprise he did what baker mayfield said
the browns should have done don't take
much
take patrick mahomes of course there
would have been no spot for baker
mayfield in cleveland a year later but
that doesn't matter mahomes watson the
top two picks of that draft and i think
you got that one right on the money no
other quarterbacks no mitchell trubisky
in the top five in the redraft so oh and
by the way are you going to be doing
2016 next 2016 today yeah yeah we're
just like basically ranking the top 10
players from that draft it is it's fun
it's just a slow time as somebody i know
says and we're looking for things to
talk about and have some fun here's the
thing
i haven't said it once this year you've
already said it 20 times so you get
you get the new moniker you're the slow
time guy not me all right so uh what
we're going to do today because we've
been talking a lot about quarterbacks
and paying young quarterbacks and when
to pay them and we talked yesterday
about that prescott's contract and i
wrote something yesterday at
profootballtalk.com about the importance
of paying that young quarterback as
quickly as you can when the window opens
because it can be a lot cheaper than if
you play it out as the cowboys are
learning the hard way so we are drafting
the best quarterbacks on their rookie
contracts but we are leaving out the
best of them all in patrick mahomes now
big cat would call this the patrick
mahomes memorial draft because it's
funny because he's still alive but i
wouldn't call it that big cat would he
would call it the patrick holmes
memorial draft so let's do what big cat
would call the patrick mahomes memorial
draft and uh chris do you have a trivia
question for me because i don't have one
for you
i got it here we go so last season at
age 24 as you know patrick mahomes
became the second youngest qb to ever
win a super bowl
michael
florio who is the youngest quarterback
to ever
win
a super bowl
hint
he is still playing okay
he's still playing ah
would you got it if i didn't give you
the hint
no i was going rothersburg or brady but
you know i i i remember hearing
something about that that
stat during super bowl week and i
remember roethlisberger's name being in
there so yeah yeah i mean does it make
you feel better if i tell you i wouldn't
have gotten it without the hint
does that make you feel uh
no it does not make me feel better it's
i'm not giving you any more hints i like
when you get it wrong no matter what
all right well i guess i have to start
with uh and
see
one of the factors here
is how long do i have this guy before i
have to repay him right or boy i have to
give him the big contract and and it
makes me want to go with a younger guy
even though the younger guy may not be
better than the guy that i want to take
but i'm just going to go with the sure
thing i'm going to go with lamar jackson
he's got two years down two years to go
then he's got the the uh the option year
and he doesn't have an agent which maybe
allows me to get him resigned at a
better rate than what otherwise would be
looking at i'm going lamar jackson the
defending mvp how can you not go lamar
jackson he can do it all one of the best
players in the nfl maybe it's him and
patrick mahomes as the best two and a
huge gap between everyone else at least
for now so i'll go lamar jackson number
one chris yeah okay i'm not mad at you
that was you know the obvious pick i
don't you know i don't want to say it
was obvious because i was sitting here
and i wasn't sure who i was going to
pick
i was you know desean watson is going to
be my pick you know yeah you know again
i understand his contract's coming up
either way he's still in a rookie
contract right now and that's what we're
drafting deshaun watson's special you
know for the chris sims offense right i
mean i'd rather have desean watson the
lamar jackson i don't know enough about
the run game and how to work your
straight all those speed sweeps and the
read option and all that stuff but from
anything where i'm looking to be more of
a pass first type offense man deshawn
watson is he's can't miss football in my
opinion he's just got it all he really
is i mean he's got a lot of special
attributes whether it's his play-making
ability the beautiful deep ball he
throws his poise in the pocket with
people around him getting kicked in the
eye and running and still throwing
touchdowns i mean you know if it weren't
for patrick mahomes
we would be singing desean watson's
phrase a whole lot more in this league
because he really really is extremely
special and honestly i think a little
bit underrated because of some of the
you know because of lamar and mahomes
and and the conversation around them
this dominate you know dominates it so
much
you know deshaun watson took the nfl by
storm as a rookie in 2017. it was that
out of the blue torn acl which he later
told us he believed was something that
happened against the seahawks the prior
sunday and then it just went the rest of
the way in practice non-contact that
thursday i remember that shock wave that
when when the text came up on my phone
and it's a desean watson has a torn acl
what are you talking about um he he
really you know the other guys jackson
in my homes it wasn't until year two
that they took off watson took off right
away and i think he has been eclipsed by
mahomes even though it's unfair to him
because watson has been every bit as
special every single year of his career
all right i'm going kyler murray the
next big thing the guy who's going to be
the third straight second year
quarterback who takes the nfl by storm i
feel it coming it's in the air and kyler
murray only has one year down
three years left plus the option year on
that rookie contract so kyla murray my
pick no brainer chris he was great last
year even if he just does what he did
last year he's going to continue to be
special i think he's going to take a
step forward especially with deshaun
watson's top weapon now in his pocket
instead of watson's yeah the the exactly
right i mean you know they're continuing
to support kyler murray with talent
around him and you know most of all you
know hey we know kylie murray's super
talented yeah i mean you're right he's a
superstar i mean special special player
but i i i saw enough from cliff
kingsbury last year to go oh cliff is
fine in the nfl yeah i got no
reservations about him you know he's
he's he's willing to adapt to the league
steal plays from other systems you know
invent new things that he thinks are
going to work within his system whatever
it may be i saw a lot of positives and i
would be shocked if yeah murray doesn't
have even a bigger year this year and
like you said it was pretty awesome last
year all right you know i'm going to go
josh allen of course you know i'm one of
the band leaders or the i'm one of the
leaders of the josh allen fan club i
love watching him play i love the person
too uh but he's special you know maybe
not as special as mahomes or watson or
lamar jackson or kyler murray but it's
not far off i mean again this is a
special special athlete and specimen
we've seen him do some things running
around scrambling that
are
deserved to be talked about in the class
of guys that we've already talked about
here his arm i mean come on i don't know
if there's a more powerful arm in
football other than maybe my homes and
rogers and josh allen it's special that
way it's a little raw still yeah but i
really think this is the year to watch
out for josh allen the buffalo bills
because they finally have something
around him now to where i go oh
they got a chance and he loves football
and continues to work and i think he
showed all of us some of the special
attributes he can bring to a team
whether it was on thanksgiving in dallas
last year or even the first three
quarters of the playoff game where he
set the bills up with a big lead over
the texan all because of his special
skills and and attributes so allen is a
guy i get really excited to watch and
and for his future
now it gets difficult yeah there's a lot
here here's my here's my very i've it
finally crystallized for me what i need
to do if joe burrow had already signed a
contract if it was him yesterday and not
to a tonga by law sorry jojo burrow i
know he doesn't have a car he's not on
his rookie contract yet so we can't take
him you can't take him either
lock i i wish drew locke was a first
round pick because i wish i had him for
four more years i only got him for three
more years before i'm in the dak
prescott situation and and again if drew
lock ends up playing well john elway you
better be ready to pay him the moment
his third regular season ends don't
string it out because it's going to cost
you more the longer you wait but give me
drew luck we saw enough from her at
least i did late last year to believe in
drew locke i'll take drew lock chris
yeah i i like that pick mike way to go
man i mean yeah i think you know again
you know i like drew lock he was my
second favorite quarterback in the draft
last year and i think he was one of
those guys that was you know the
struggles of the team in college were
placed on him but i think he's gonna
kill it this year i would be shocked if
he doesn't you know what mike i'm gonna
kind of go a different way here too i'm
not gonna go with like some of the other
names i'm gonna go with daniel jones
daniel jones is going to be my third
pick i loved what i saw from daniel
jones last year he was the mvp of the
new york giants football team listen his
biggest issue is an issue that i can
deal with and i actually almost semi
semi-like to a degree his issue was
fumbling right okay well it wasn't like
he was fumbling because he was like
let's say a josh allen or just crazy
outside the pocket and doing some crazy
things no he had a his only issue was
fumbling because one the o-line wasn't
great but two the guy is absolutely
fearless in the pocket like if there's
something he needs to just get a little
bit better at is like hey get out of the
pocket you're a really good athlete and
you can rip off 20 and 30 yard runs
you're that type of guy but man when you
talk about not big time talent around
him and some of the games that he played
last year with four touchdown
performances and no interceptions and
three touchdown performance and no
interceptions he did a lot of great
stuff with a less than you know a less
than healthy saquon barkley an average
o-line and really no household names at
wide receiver either
uh i really like where what i saw from
daniel jones i think he could be special
all right i've got lamar jackson carla
murray drew lock chris has desean watson
josh allen and daniel jones that is what
big cat would call the patrick mahomes
memorial draft best quarterbacks playing
on a rookie contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports